[Music]
let's get started with the controversy
over Megan Markos appearance at the
annual trooping the colour did the
duchess break royal protocol by varying
too much skin at the official
celebration of the Queen's birthday
Megan's one-of-a-kind
off the shoulder dress by Carolina
Herrera caused quite a stir Megan hasn't
breached any royal protocol as such as
far as the Queen was concerned no issue
with Megan showing those shoulders I
think perhaps for some of the
traditionalists out there they might
have preferred to have seen Megan a
little more covered up Megan and Harry
reportedly had a top secret honeymoon in
East Africa and many were wondering why
was the Duchess of Sussex standing in
the back row behind Duchess Kate the
order of hierarchy deems that Megan
comes after the Duchess of Cambridge and
the Duke of Cambridge we're not always
going to see her in Kate's shadow I
think particularly when they're not in
the presence of the Queen at such a
formal event you'll see them much more
on an equal footing the royal kids were
front and center enjoying the Air Force
spy over and talk about cheeky Savannah
Phillips the Queen's great-granddaughter
tried to shush her cousin Prince George
and even put her hand over his mouth
three-year-old Princess Charlotte had a
brief meltdown but mama Kate scooped her
up to calm her down
Sunday it was a totally different more
laid-back day for Kate and the kids
Charlotte skipped barefoot in the grass
while watching her dad Prince William
play polo Prince George seemed happy and
carefree and his preppy shorts and polo
shirt and Kate showed us she can be
frugal and fashionable in a summer dress
by Zara that costs under $70 and you can
buy it at a model
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]